there it is there's Lex  oh  [Music]  that's pretty good  relax can shred give me some of that  you got to listen to this listen to this  [Music]  [Applause]  have you done Lexus podcast  no you'd love him he's uh an AI  researcher from MIT originally now he's  mostly doing independent work and doing  his own podcast and  brilliant brilliant guy  you would love him and he's got an  amazing podcast too  okay so here it's going to be in this  section I don't know if you're  interested in Lex's podcast  seems like he's not paying attention no  hang on  I got this  well thank you for the tip I'm trying to  get him on buddy try to get him in  Lex actually  is one of the most brilliant people I  know  I think you would love talking to him  um  or an interesting quote here from Walter  badshot  one of the greatest pains to Human  Nature  is the pain of a new idea  really  that guy's an idiot that's not the  greatest pain someone needs to kick him  in the neck